c'est toujours leur de babar issa avec
bravo loto le jeu 100% gratuit qui peut
changer ta vie
téléchargez l'appli jeter gris et tente
de remporter jusqu'à un million d'euros
sans rien faire bravo l'auto facile
d'être riche
les bramais enfilé marseille j'ai fait
tout ça mais que déplorer
un truc
je suis
sans faire
[Musique]
on avait par contre la rose
maintenant on rentre sans rien
non non non non non rien de ses canons
voiture est comme ça ça me revient
j'ai passé la maturité des malades
poursuit hubert joly ce qu'il te retiens
pas longtemps non sans déconner combien
s'était passé n'était pas dépasser par
eddy mitchell confiant sur le double
était pas star l'a redit on dirait
estivale aux directives de dégarnir le
mouvement à illzach
lâchez-moi agression autre chose je veux
que tu sois star mecelec voilà tepa star
mon chéri la voix la liste noire six
mois tu me fais pas confiance est bon on
arrête tout j'imagine que la prime
j'imagine que tu y es tu encore plus
quand price a fait inscrire ta famille
ont 6 et le groupe à fait normal
je suis venue d un véhicule et a pas une
cape vous donnez 100 m derrière
non je suis torse nu à au programme d'as
juste
qu'est ce qu'il ya au coeur du plus sexy
oui le plus glamour mais bon lesquels il
faut le tribunal t'es un connard est la
voie la suite du pont avec un dé la moi
je dirais même plus je suis du pont des
cannes des athées non à des sétois le
[Rires]
témoin je ne parlerais pas vers qui
n'est ce pas le sentir à la maison toute
façon je suis un garçon est pour eux le
dire je ne peux que te vire parce que
sans contrefaçon
[Musique]
vous avez par fermer boutique
j'ai par contre oui oui
[Musique]